my name is Evan Britton and I consume  cannabis before I trained cannabis  really helped me come out of my and a  fell career with my brain intact and was  able to leave the goals behind me this  is a instantize THC powder  cannabis has an effect of softening the  focus it puts you into another plane of  consciousness where the mind-body  connection is fortified the mindful  warrior podcast we wanted to use that as  a channel to talk about combining the  warrior spirit with these holistic  healing practices anibus enhances our  awareness and our perspective on you  know the world and our surroundings  giving you a much more you know  beneficial experience beneficial  worked-out training regimen whatever it  is  [Music]